une grève diversement suivis chez
renault où la production est très
ralentie dans trois usines du groupe
plusieurs débrayages ce matin à l' usine
de billancourt 1 après le pactole airbus
un nouveau contrat franco américain
cette fois c'est ibm qui commandent des
composants électroniques à thomson la
chine populaire fêtait aujourd'hui ses
35 ans l anniversaire placé sous le
signe de la modernisation et puis
invités de ce journal nastassja kinski
prost les salles de cinéma parisiennes
ce titre on peut la voir cette semaine
c'est dans trois pays différents dont le
dernier est maria stover ce qui sort
mercredi
mesdames messieurs bonsoir c'est la
tension chez renault qui fournit ce soir
encore l'essentiel de l'actualité
sociale en france renault où la cgt a
décidé de mener ce lundi un double test
en appelant à des actions dans tous les
établissements de la région
de cette façon la centrale d'henri
krasucki veut évaluer la combativité et
le moral de ses troupes dans ce qui est
considéré comme l'un de ses bastions
et puis du même coup et c'est le
deuxième point la cgt lance sa première
offensive sérieuse contre le
gouvernement et la politique initiée par
laurent fabius c'est la première fois
qu'elle défie ainsi le gouvernement
depuis que les communistes l'ont quitté
le bilan de cette journée d'action avec
geneviève moll et jean marc dubois
sur les douze usines de la régie trois
points chauds encore ce soir doit
sandouville et cléon comme vous le voyez
sur cette carte sous forme de pastilles
rouges dans ses trois usines la
production a été soit quasi nuls soit
très ralentie simplement en pastilles
rouges aussi est en grève illimitée
mais cette usine ne compte que 500
salariés contre 16 milles par exemple à
flins où les chaînes ont tourné
normalement en rose sur la carte
boulogne billancourt ou des débrayages
ont eu lieu ce matin uniquement dans les
autres usines en vert sur la carte pas
d'arrêt de travail
la poursuite de la grève a été votée par
l'équipe de l'après-midi à main levée
alors que ce matin l'intersyndicale
avait organisé un vote dit secret plus
in a cependant tourné au tiers de sa
capacité avec les non-grévistes de la
première équipe
il en a été à peu près de même cet après
midi avec la seconde équipe
des piquets de grève occupent maintenant
les différentes portes de l'entreprise
mais les grévistes ne peuvent plus
pénétrer dans les ateliers la direction
filtrant les entrées
il est impossible de dire ce soit si le
mouvement se durcit rend une lourd a
doublé ce qui est sûr c'est que la base
suit mollement la manifestation dans la
ville ce matin le mot très bien
la cgt annoncé 1500 manifestants il y en
avait à peine simple enfin la cfdt et fo
semble de plus en plus réticentes à
suivre la cgt dans une grève dont la
coloration politique
leur part est elie d'hôtes et essaie
quand même de l'emploi la première chose
qu'on défend et on se battra d'avant là
dessus parce que pour moi que ça va se
battre sur une prime si vous perdez à
l'emploi pourtant l'unité syndicale
résiste encore jusqu'à quand la réponse
est probablement dans l'intervention
vent et gravity ce soir à l'heure de
vérité sur antenne 2 6 heures celle
embauche de la première équipe à
billancourt
après l'appel lancé hier par la cgt un
leitmotiv dans les discussions il va se
passer quelque chose aujourd'hui
souvent c'est en ça va gérer ses revenus
non à débrayer un bon coup vous fera par
une heure et demie ça sera deux jours
trois jours cible le faut car jo qu'est
ce que vous allez faire sont atteints on
va certainement pas faire grand chose
11 heures la cgt annonce que des
débrayages ont eu lieu dans la matinée à
l'île seguin 14h30 à l'heure dans la
relève certains sont satisfaits des
actions menées la veille et apprenez lui
remettent ça allez vous avaient débrayé
combien de temps dure année
et après la poupe ils ont parfois mais
pour la direction seulement 700 ouvriers
sur 5000 ont effectivement d'ebrié
débrayé ce matin vous avez travaillé cet
après midi il n'y a eu aucun arrêt de
travail et rien n'est encore prévu pour
mardi
demain à midi andré saint-jean leader de
la métallurgie cgt sera reçue par la
direction de la régie renault pour
parler des sureffectifs
oui ce conflit chez renault sera bien
sûr au centre des discussions dans
l'émission l'heure de vérité qui a ce
soir pour invité henri krasucki à 20h35
sur antenne 2 la présence d'henri
krasucki tombe à point nommé puisqu'il
aura le loisir d'exprimer sa position
sur ce conflit test de la cgt et sur
l'attitude à venir de sa centrale face à
la politique économique du gouvernement
henri krasucki que vous voyez vient
d'arriver dans nos studios des buttes
chaumont
vous savez que vous pouvez lui poser des
questions au cours de cette émission il
vous suffit pour cela d'appeler dès
maintenant le 787 pour 11 c'est-à-dire
svp 11 11
si vous êtes la province vous devez
faire précéder ce numéro 10 prix fixe 16
et 1 l'heure de vérité
juste après ce journal à 20h35 monsieur
krasucki sur interviewé par albert du
roy alain duhamel et guides qu'est-ce
qui est directeur de la rédaction du
matin
un autre leader syndical andré bergeron
a mis le gouvernement il patronat en
garde contre des conflits très sérieux
dans les semaines à venir
monsieur bergeron parler bien sûr de
renous mais pas seulement de renous ce
sont 4 général de force ouvrière qui
était l'invitée d'antenne du midi
souhaite que l'on dit que l'on étudie
les problèmes aux faux et que les
arrière pensées politiques ne
l'emportent pas sur le contenu des
dossiers la cgt c'est à dire en fait le
parti communiste utilise toutes les
possibilités qui s'offrent à eux pour
combattre la politique du gouvernement
mais cela dit laissons ça de côté un
instant si vous voulez il ya le problème
lui-même le problème qui fait que des
gens ne parvenant plus à faire face à
leurs obligations réagissent c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau
les histoires de date fixée pour une
négociation dans la mesure où le climat
se dégrade
tout ça ne pèse plus vous comprenez les
gens en ont assez et réagissent
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas encore une très
en pleurs parce que ceux qui ont du
travail disent nous avons au moins ça
pour le reste on verra plus tard mais
vous verrez dans les semaines qui
viennent si le gouvernement et les
employeurs ne comprennent pas ce que je
ne cesse de dire depuis longtemps vous
verrez qu'il y aura des conflits sociaux
sérieux comme on n'en avait pas connu
depuis longtemps
oui le président du cnpm monsieur gattaz
estime dans une interview que publie
demain le quotidien de paris que le
conflit de la régie renault est une
mauvaise action pour l'industrie
automobile française toute entière à la
veille de l'ouverture du salon de
l'autre en marge du conflit sur renault
et d'informations qui intéressent la
régie mais dans son secteur compétition
avec le renouvellement du contrat de
patrick tambay et de derek warwick sur
formule 1 une troisième voiture sera
conduite par philippe streiff qui a
récemment gagné à brands hatch en
formule 2 il n'est donc plus question
apparemment de niki lauda dont les
exigences financières semblent est il
est vrai des mesures et à un moment où
l'on parle de dégraissage al arich
les industriels américains trouvent
décidément bien du charme aux
entreprises françaises
on est à peine revenu du fabuleux
contrat passé entre paname et airbus
industrie qu'un autre contrat presque
aussi important vient d'être signé entre
la société française thomson et le géant
américain de l'informatique ibm thompson
fabriquera des puces pour les américains
ce qui devrait rapporter plusieurs
centaines de millions de francs chaque
année sur au moins trois ans et puis
surtout cet accord va permettre de créer
500 emplois dans une région qui en a
bien besoin
en l'occurrence la lorraine le reportage
de guy schwarz et patrick voit dans
moins d'un an cet animal devra brouter
ailleurs en effet à partir d'octobre
prochain
le prêt verdoyant aura fait place à une
usine de composants électroniques
une usine qui emploiera près de 500
personnes à la fin de 1986
dans le même temps celles que possèdent
déjà le groupe thomson dans la région
d'aix-en-provence aura vu son activité
doublé certes le marché de
l'électronique va continuer à croître
mais si le groupe français a décidé
d'investir dans ces opérations et sommes
considérables c'est surtout parce qu'il
vient de décrocher un énorme contrat ibm
le géant américain de l'informatique a
décidé en effet de lui acheter chaque
année pour plusieurs centaines de
millions de francs de composants ces
composants corps ont en particulier dans
les ordinateurs qu'elle assemble en
écosse ainsi malgré ses déboires récents
avec un fournisseur américain ibm
n'hésite pas à s'adresser à des
européens comme si elle cherchait à
s'attirer les bonnes grâces des pays où
elle est implantée
nous avons la volonté de coopérer avec
l'industrie nationale dans le cadre du
bn france l'industrie française cette
volonté de coopération existe dans tous
les pays dans lequel ibm dans tous les
pays européens dans lesquels ibm est
implanté je dirais qu'elle va au delà
d'ailleurs d'une coopération avec
industrie puisque en ce qui concerne la
france nous coopérons aussi avec
l'université en participant un certain
nombre de projets d'avant-garde pour
l'enseignement et l'étude et la
fabrication des composants
si le contrat signé entre ibm et thomson
semble positif pour l'entreprise
française
il faut tout de même dire il
enthousiasme le cocardier en effet pour
fabriquer les composants dont ibm a
besoin thomson acheter des licences à un
groupe japonais
en achetant effectivement un certain
nombre de savoir-faire au japon ça me
permet en particulier dynamisme des
exportations je vous donnais deux
chiffres nos exportations sont passées
lors de 30% monsieur d'affaires deux ans
à 65 % cette année alors je pense que ça
ne va aller qu'en s'amplifiant et que
les accords qu'on aurait à dijon
autrement vont accélérer ce phénomène
n'était pas et pas être un frein
donc considérer que les centaines de
millions de francs d'investissements que
vous avez consentir seront rentabilisés
ans seulement n'a conscient on le
considère mais on ne ferait pas si on
n'était pas sûr tant qu ibm se fournira
chez thomson sans aucun doute encore
faudra-t-il qu'il ne se contente pas
d'imiter les japonais
à noter aussi toujours au chapitre des
grandes manoeuvres industriels a noté
l'accord signé entre honda motor et des
cycles peugeot la société japonaise
entre dans le capital d'une filiale des
cycles peugeot après deux ans de
coopération dans le secteur du
cyclomoteur et du scooter et puis vous
devez savoir que le syndicat national
des contrôleurs aériens a déclenché
aujourd'hui un mouvement de suspension
des décollages qui entraînera jusqu'au 3
octobre des perturbations variables
selon les jours et ce lot les aéroports
un petit garçon de 10 ans est mort
samedi des suites d'une opération en
principe très banal puisque l'enfant
était tout simplement opéré de
l'appendicite
après la plainte déposée par les parents
c'est une nouvelle fois la surveillance
après l'opération qui est mise en cause
le moment où l'anesthésique continue de
présenter des risques
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'un pareil accident se produit en
france même si les précautions très
sévères sont en principe prises pour
éviter de pareilles à faire le récit de
jérôme k ni l'intervention chirurgicale
a eu lieu samedi dans un finish du val
d'oise le petit vincent un enfant de 10
ans il subissait une opération
parfaitement codifié le personnel
hospitalier formel tout était
parfaitement normale après
l'intervention
l'enfant a été conduit en salle de
réveil et l'anesthésiste après avoir
constaté le réveil post opératoire avait
autorisé le retour de l'enfant dans sa
chambre ce soir 48 heures après l'équipe
médicale ne comprends toujours pas
l'intervention s'est terminée vers 10h10
ce moment-là sorti l'enfant de la salle
d'opération et on a mis là dans cette
salle de réveil que vous voyez
d'ailleurs on en est en train de se
réveiller
et je les gardais la 20 minute je lui
demandais de me regarder dans les yeux
les appeler par son nom il a ouvert les
yeux
je lui demandais de tirer la langue il a
tiré la langue
et puis je les passais il a bougé en
france à bouger donc si vous voulez
partant en partant de là on considère
que
il a éliminé les drogues anesthésie qui
a un retour la conscience puisqu'il
comprend les ordres simples qu'on lui
demande et par conséquent on peut
considérer que anne et éthiquement
parlant le malade c'est à dire sur cet
enfant là été réveillé et encore une
fois le réveil anesthésique étant
terminée c'est un problème de de sommeil
post post réveillez vous et je souscris
parfaitement avec une de la famille qui
a demandé y remportant plata découvrir
la vérité je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec le fait que je veux savoir la
vérité parce que mon fils à savoir où
j'en attend maintenant les résultats de
l'autopsié pour établir les
responsabilités
après un week-end tendue mais sans
incident significatif le climat était
plutôt à l'apaisement au pays basque
français et espagnol et cela malgré
l'arrestation samedi à biarritz de
tomassi nazza considéré comme l'un des
principaux responsables de letea
militaire madrid a demandé son
extradition
apaisement donc dans la tente de la
décision de paris et alors même que le
principal responsable basque le
président du gouvernement autonome
demande que tout soit fait pour que la
paix revienne dans la province
l'inauguration d'un nouveau tronçon
routier devoir d'une fonction carlos
carrasco et chea est ce qu'on appelle
ici le lehendakari entendez le chef du
gouvernement autonome basque
élu au suffrage universel c'est la plus
haute autorité du pays
il est membre du pnv le parti
nationaliste basque un parti modéré qui
représente ici plus de 40% des suffrages
le rôle de carlos carrasco et shia est
délicat il est l'interlocuteur officiel
de madrid
mais c'est aussi un ardent défenseur de
la cause basque hier encore il déclarait
qu ici même
le taa dispose d'un soutien populaire
tout à fait réelle voyons du hockey
papier mais et la polio dans sa
chronique le théâtre dispose
soutien d'un secteur minoritaire mais
non négligeable du peuple basque et
naissance la constatation le constat est
exact de ce qu'est le thé à letea
représente la polio lectorale à peu près
14 à 15% des suffrages on sait les
élections notre budget important reste
de la population et à avaux la majorité
qui restent a choisi des chemins précis
fixé ce qui constitue le gouvernement
autonome du pays basque
l'espace est mon film maior supporter
électorale je croyais
vous serez signer medio pensez vous
qu'on puisse craindre pour les intérêts
français au pays basque espagnol
non aux prix revenant you look et le
mélo va existons notre part la première
des choses c'est d'assurer un maximum de
protection pour les intérêts français
et puis j'espère ce moment de colère ne
fera pas faire pour le sentiment
d'hospitalité ce qui anime la grande
majorité du peuple basque
le temps c'est de l'argent l'efficacité
c'est la vie ou encore vive le système
de responsabilité ces slogans ne sont
pas américains mais chinois la
république populaire de chine fêtait
aujourd'hui ses 35 ans puisqu'elle a vu
le jour le 1er octobre 1949
et à en juger par le défilé sur la place
tiananmen ce matin la chine n'en finit
pas de changer puisque aujourd'hui cet
anniversaire était placée sous le signe
de la modernisation et du réalisme
maurice werther pour ce 35e anniversaire
contrairement à ce qui s'était passé
l'an dernier où il n'y avait eu aucune
manifestation sur la place tienanmen des
autorités de la république populaire ont
décidé de revenir à la tradition et de
faire défiler dans un ordre qu on
admirera d'abord l'armée
sans oublier et détachement féminin sur
le plan technique les observateurs
étrangers compétents ont pu constater
que l'armement chinois c'est
relativement moderniser y compris en
matière nucléaire politiquement la chine
a sans doute voulu signifier à certains
voisins inquiétant qu avec les années
elle est de plus en plus à même de se
défendre
mais le message ne s'arrête pas là cet
envol d'oiseaux est évidemment
symbolique la chine même si elle
n'oublie pas ma autres on verra très
brièvement passé un buste la chine veut
la paix elle veut s'ouvrir au monde se
modernise et de façon à satisfaire les
aspirations de la population
symbolique encore un char de parade
représentant tout un village en liesse
avec danses et tim quand la réalité est
encore très différemment
il y a des besoins élémentaires qui ne
sont toujours pas satisfaits et
aujourd'hui la fête permet de faire
oublier les aspects les plus noires de
la réalité il y a eu plusieurs milliers
d'exécutions capitales châtiment en
principe de crimes de droit commun
en fait de combien du délit politique
oui puis ce matin aussi l'organe du
parti communiste chinois le quotidien du
peuple a lancé un appel taiwan pour
négocier le rattachement de la chine
nationaliste est à dire taiwan à la
chine populaire
incident au temple d'or d'amritsar dans
l'état du pendjab où nord de l'inde des
militants s'ils comptent occuper ce
matin au lieu de leur religion
l'armée est intervenue pour les déloger
vous souvenez que l'été dernier
des combats très violents avaient fait
plus de 600 morts entre forces de
l'ordre et intégristes de la minorité
sic dans ce même temple de ridder les
révélations de tommaso buscetta le roi
de la drogue a permis à la police
italienne de mener une opération sans
précédent contre les responsables de la
mafia dans ce pays
366 mandats d'arrêt ont été lancés
contre les responsables de
l'organisation dont certains sont déjà
en prison
bref c'est la structure même de la mafia
qui accuse le coup aujourd'hui alors que
l'on parle de possibles conséquences sur
le milieu américain infiltré justement
par la mafia de rome victor vraiment
dommage au bush est le parrain repenti a
déjà subi deux opérations de chirurgie
esthétique
alors qu'il était en fuite quelque part
au brésil autant dire qu'il vaut mieux
ne pas essayer de savoir à quoi il
ressemble exactement on sait qu'il est
né à palerme la capitale de la sicile
il ya 56 ans
profession trafiquant international de
drogue entre la sicile brésil le mexique
et les états unis et ce devait être un
caïd particulièrement influent puisqu'il
a été relâché il ya 15 ans par le préfet
de police de palerme est qu'aux états
unis il a évité la prison en payant une
amende de 75 mille dollars
on le voit ici alors qu'il arrive à rome
au mois de juillet c'est que finalement
il a été extradé du brésil
ce qui d'ailleurs laisse penser qu'il a
été abandonné par la mafia
internationale
tommaso bouchette était trop gourmand il
était déjà milliardaires mais il voulait
encore le contrôle absolu d'une zone de
palerme la ville où il est né
c'est sans doute un sentimental on peut
aller loin dans la mafia mais pas trop
c'est la guerre
sept membres de la famille bush états
sont assassinés bouchetta n'a plus rien
à perdre complètement isolé dans une
cellule spéciale dans une prison au
mieux on ne sait pas laquelle garder ou
plutôt protégé jour et nuit
bush est un livre donc les noms des
commanditaires et des exécutants 221
assassinat pour le compte de la mafia
par exemple boucher a expliqué que c'est
un sommet de plusieurs familles
mafieuses de palerme et de catane qui a
décidé qu'il fallait tuer le général
carlo alberto da la pièce qui commençait
à comprendre comment fonctionnait le
trafic de la drogue
or le fils du général dalla qu'ils nam
d'eau va encore plus loin dans un livre
qui sortira en france à la mi-octobre
d'après nombre total acquise le meurtre
de son père a été parrainée par les
protecteurs politiques de la mafia à
palerme
or ces hommes politiques locaux les jo
les lima et les cheng chi minh à tous
démocrates chrétiens seraient à leur
tour des clients d'un homme politique
célèbre et influent giulio andreotti
actuellement ministre des affaires
étrangères le général dalla qu'ils
auraient écrit dans son journal
quand j'y racontais andreotti tout ce
que je savais sur ces hommes en sicile
est devenu pâle nom de dallas qu'ils
auraient demandé à son père mais qui est
contre toi
le général aurait répondu ceux du
courant andreotti
on peut donc dire que bush est un membre
d'al à kiev ont ouvert la voie au même
moment à quelque chose qui pourrait
ressembler un tremblement de terre
politique au criminel ou un sujet fort
intéressant pour les policiers
américains italiens qui devraient se
rencontrer cette semaine à new york pour
coordonner leur lutte contre la
criminalité
une réunion de travail consacrée au sort
de jacques à bouchard s'est tenue
aujourd'hui à l'elysée à l'initiative de
jean-louis bianco qui est secrétaire
général de la présidence
voici maintenant quatorze jours que
jacques bouchard est aux mains des
forces soviéto afghane après sa capture
alors qu'ils étaient en reportage dans
la région aujourd'hui tout est fait pour
tenter d'entrer en contact avec lui car
personne n'a vu jacques depuis que les
afghans ont officiellement confirmé
qu'il était prisonnier et c'est un souci
bien sûr pour nous tous je vous rappelle
l'adresse du comité à bouchard vous
pouvez écrire pour apporter votre
soutien à notre ami au 33 rue du louvre
75002 paris
jacquat bouchard qui est donc détenus en
afghanistan depuis maintenant deux
semaines
en principe ce qui fait le prestige
d'une équipe
et quel que soit le sport pratiqué c'est
son goût de la victoire son acharnement
à l'emporter sur l'adversaire c'est par
exemple l'image de concentration d'un
carl lewis pour parler de l'athlète le
plus connu du monde
mais vaincre ce n'est pas toujours
facile est l'un des grands moments du
forum international du film sportif qui
se tenait à montpellier le week-end
dernier
ce moment ce fut sans conteste la
projection d'un film qui raconte le
calvaire d'une équipe qui ne gagne
jamais vraiment jamais son titre encore
un foutu dimanche
il y est question de jeu à xiii et vous
allez le voir l'équipe en question n'a
vraiment pas la chance dans son camp
heureusement il lui reste l'humour
roger sa mère
quand un vrai reportage devient un
véritable film avec scénario et acteur
dans l'histoire est belle dramatiques
parfois émouvant et souvent drôle
et dans the bloody sunday encore un
foutu dimanche c'est la triste aventure
d'un club de 2e division britannique de
jeu à xiii celui de doncaster dans le
yorkshire
doncaster a cette particularité de ne
jamais gagné un match et le réalisateur
de ce film barry cockroft a suivi ce
club dans ses malheurs avec un regard
plein d'humour et de tendresse
dans le championnat de division 2 le
bilan est facile
doncaster dernier 19 matches 19 défaites
zéro point mais cela n'empêche pas
l'assiduité d'un petit groupe de
supporters très très britannique
je suis là les plus anciens je les
encourage depuis très longues années
mais c'est réellement la plus mauvaise
équipe de jeu à xiii que j'ai vu après
22 défaites
les dirigeants ont tout essayé dans le
vestiaire le président à bout
d'arguments augmentent les primes de
match
en désespoir de cause
m
mais il n'y a rien à faire doncaster est
le club le plus malchanceux et sans
aucun doute également le plus obstiné
des îles britanniques
comment gars les encouragements du
manager n'y changeront rien c'est la
défaite numéro 23
à combien jours reviennent les primes de
matches par saison
cela vaut environ 1000 livres par saison
ça c'est quand vous perdez mais quand
vous gagnez vous les payez plus cher
non mais on n'est pas combien pour
savoir il faut que je consulte les
archives et comme dans toutes les belles
histoires il y a une fin heureuse après
82 heures passées sur le terrain sans
gagner dangas terre va remporter sa
première victoire
ces cas là c'est vraiment l'humour qui
fait la différence du film sportif nous
passons au cinéma tout court avec notre
invité la comédienne nastassja kinski
qu'on ne présente plus bonsoir nastassia
alors on peut vous voir aujourd'hui à
paris dans trois films différents en
tout cas à partir de mercredi il y à
paris texas bien sûr il y à l'automne ni
hampshire
et puis il ya mario se lover c'est le
petit dernier alors qu'est ce que cette
marianne lover ce soir
plutôt une histoire qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que la guerre fait aux hommes
il ya et c'est une histoire de ce jeune
homme qui vient de la guerre et qui est
qui qui est pas mort mais qui est pas
mort à cause qu'il a qu'il a tenu un
rêve qui est nul à l'amour qu'il a tenu
pour possible
c'est une histoire d'amour mais c'est ce
que je voulais dire que haut du bus et
un documentaire
s'il ya quelques minutes un documentaire
de john huston qui la tournée du vrai
matériel qu'il a tourné des hommes qui
sont venus de la guerre qui sont
interviewés par des psychiatres et on
voit vraiment les raisons c'est pas un
film ça c'est du vrai matériel les
hommes comme comme ils ont changé comme
ils ont dit turbé commises en plus plus
les ans on vraiment c'est un seul c'est
presque un miracle qui sorte qu'ils
sortent vivants mais même s'ils sont
vivants physiquement beaucoup de fois
ils sont morts morts comme comme ça
c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui a bon
kiki qui vient chez soi et voilà à la
fin mais voilà avec cette famille peut
pas vivre et ni faire l'amour ni rien
parce qu' il a tenus
cette femme comme un amour spirituel
quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas toucher
les écoles voilà alors quand même
finalement avec ce film que nous
préparer pour nous france roche tout de
suite si on peut voir cet extrait voilà
dans deux petites secondes
un extrait donc deux mariages lovers
oui mais oui
tél wen et que ça très court mais très
représentative du climat du film oui
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à faire
l'amour avec sa femme elle elle est
complètement désespéré et pourquoi
pourquoi elle veut mourir et c'est
l'enfer dans cette maison avec ses deux
jeunes gens et à la fin elle lui apporte
un enfant d'un autre parce qu'elle est
vierge et avec ça celui dans un tel choc
quel est celui dans la force de revenir
hsa fameux de faire l'amour avec un pour
la première fois mais c'est ça c'est
tellement fort que c'est ça promettait
montant de casser le cauchemar de la
guerre est allé au festival de venise
est une habituée des festivals j'ai
regardé votre biographie vous ai fait
parce que tous les festivals vous étiez
à cannes
c'est par une hausse car pour thèse que
vous étiez à cannes la câline dans le
caniveau de beineix la palme d'or donc
avec paris texas et matin vous allez à
venir comment faites vous vous
choisissez vos réalisateur comment ça se
passe on peut pas expliquer c'est une
communication entre l'acteur réalisateur
si vous à l'aube ce qui par exemple qui
est donc l'homme qui a réalisé ce
malaise lover
comment avez vous choisi pourquoi cet
homme parce que j'ai eu il ya quelques
années j'ai vu ces trois films le
premier m on peut gagner cyber yade et
je le trouvais comme suit - fantastique
et après quelques années on se veut
paraître accident comme ça je voulais
faire un film j'ai dit pourquoi vous ne
faites pas avec moi parce que c'est une
histoire très personnelle à moi aussi
c'est comme ça c'est son principe mais
c'est plutôt comme je vous avais dit
avant le metteur en scène avant histoire
parce que c'est le mécanicien dont les
moteurs du tout alors c'est ce que nous
lisons partant merci le feu s'est
inscrit donc maria spurs à partir de
mercredi sur les écrans parisiens et
dans un petit instant le tente de
recaler les caméras nous allons
découvrir alain gillot-pétré et sa très
bonne mine puisque leur revient de
vacances
alain gillot-pétré peut-être dans
quelques secondes
vous avez eu un monsieur météo qui n'a
paru le soleil qui ne va pas au soleil
cela dit pour nous pas de chance ça va
de mal en pis où ça va de pis en mal on
va tâcher d'arranger
mais regardez la photo satellite elle
est terrible vous avez ici une première
perturbation qui est passée aujourd'hui
le dessus de nos têtes elle s'évacue
vers les avait une deuxième derrière qui
se creusent et vous avez une troisième
pour demain soir ça nous laisse le temps
d'avoir une carte lamentable pour demain
regardez là le matin donc vous aurez
toujours de la pluie avec beaucoup de
nuages du nord-est au jura aux alpes et
à la corse s'évacuera lentement vers
l'est
il y aura du beau temps autour de la
méditerranée ce qui inclut les
pyrénées-orientales et les cévennes mais
une deuxième zone depuis ce matin sur
l'ouest se situera à 12h du nord au
bassin parisien au massif central et aux
pyrénées occidentales se déplaçant vers
l'est ensuite un peu d'instabilité de
l'appui des nuages du soleil puis une
nouvelle zone de pluie en fin de journée
avec un peu moins de prix mais toujours
autant de nuages
bref c'est lamentable côté température
de 15 à 17 degrés sur la moitié nord et
de 16 à 22 degrés sur la moitié sud
températures qui sont en baisse et qui
continuent à baisser
hélas je vous dis qu'on va tâcher
d'arranger ça mais laissez moi le temps
demain mardi 2 octobre quatre minutes de
calyon mois à paris lever 650 et une
couche et 18h27
après c'est la salle jules et oui et
c'est bernard cadinot qui vous
présentera le tout dernier journal aux
environs de 23 heures 20 demain 12h40
cinquantaine de midi noël mamère 18h30
c'est la vie et je vous retrouverai à
20h enfin je vous rappelle que juste
après la publicité
vous avez rendez vous avec l'heure de
vérité qui a pour invité henri krasucki
très bonne soirée à demain 20 heures